what's up ladies and gentlemen yeah
Saturday time for another sidetrack yeah
I don't know what we're gonna talk about
today other than stuff maybe stuff we
watched last night I'm so tired and we
have to record a episode tonight later
on I got my gargoyles in oh yeah I'm
putting together Terminator one costume
gargoyle glasses I got the engineer
boots got the got those awful auction
off he bears a lot of good deals on eBay
right now
well yeah like I said probably
everybody's like yeah there's not money
in those glasses were like not normally
they're like 90 bucks for a set of
goggles I got him for like 35 yeah
trying to figure how to make that grey
shirt but I had forgotten about when you
showed me the picture of those boots I
had forgotten that my dad actually had a
pair of boots yeah a little H artist
engineer whose kid yeah yeah actually
that's from the 60s
those boots are from the 60s yeah
they're like motorcycle boots from the
film six yeah well my dad used to ride
motorcycles yeah yeah so um what I was
just gonna say something what oh one
thing that we discovered today and maybe
yeah if you guys didn't know this we
don't seen it we never think about doing
this we have several streaming services
right we have Netflix we have shudder
yeah we have the to be at AMC yeah we
have the AMC thing like which now does
streaming because of you know everyone
knows why however we always forget about
Expo about the Xbox yeah store yeah like
you've bought a lot of games and [ __ ] on
there but it's like they have a [ __ ] ton
of movies yeah that you can rent or buy
and we always forget to look on there
the rental stuff is [ __ ] new some of
those movies are weeks old yes so we
were looking around today and it's like
there's a [ __ ] ton of like indie horror
films on there that actually a lot of
them look really good yeah there's a
Andy action film on there called guns
akimbo
yeah with Daniel Radcliffe that looks
[ __ ] awesome so I was like that's
cool because now we can and they're only
like three or four bucks to rent them
yeah so that's good because we'll have
like a bunch of matinee stuff yeah and
some of them
movies that are in the theater right now
you can watch them but yeah yeah it's
usually like 20 bucks like I said you
know that's fair enough because you know
I just not make money but I do not
believe that well it's not the theaters
it's the studio's I guess but or some
kind of distributor but all that's
that's all old-fashioned [ __ ] yeah that
that old [ __ ] Hollywood system of
having distributors and films and
Shelley they don't need that they don't
need that anymore that's what we were
looking at some of those independent
films and were like they didn't even
show they did even show trailers of that
for AMC that never showed that at AMC
well they were ever in the theater they
were never in the theaters but they were
like better the some of those trailers
look better than the trailers they were
showing us in the damn theaters yeah
like guns akimbo I'd rather I would have
gone to scene that is that looks super
fun yeah and some of those horror movies
that that they didn't they didn't even
play a show yeah a couple of them I had
heard of because like I said I try to
keep track of like you know the
festivals and stuff but some of them I
hadn't heard of in then we watched the
trailers I'm like hey looks pretty good
there's one on there called the ascent
that looks [ __ ] cool yeah it's like
an exorcism yeah like a demon yeah and
you could tell they had some practical
effects and there's something like from
beyond this big [ __ ] glob yeah so uh
so it's exciting so there was like
enough [ __ ] on there that we will
probably would never run out of stuff to
review for the matinee show some of that
stuff I'm telling you so many stuff look
better than what they were trying to
show us that AMC in the big theaters
yeah you know there's no sense in
killing AMC app they're not charging us
right now yeah they're not charging
until cuz they you know they're like
well you can't cover the theater so yeah
and I think I think by the time this
shit's over there's a good chance that a
lot of their theaters may not reopen
yeah so maybe that's why they're not
charging people and maybe I'm not really
sure how well that one does by by us
like by the Altamonte mall it always
seems like when big movies open it
always seems like really crowded yeah
but it's only this first opening days
and it's at night yeah I mean we usually
go like in the afternoon weekdays and
stuff just cuz I don't like to sit my
stead
yeah I'm lying around in people that's
what I mean I don't usually like to see
movies with cuz no one can shut up yeah
you know what I mean dudes [ __ ] fart
and [ __ ] feet up on the back of the damn
table dudes wearing no shoes in the
theater that [ __ ] I don't like be
around [ __ ] nasty feet and [ __ ]
yeah he doesn't like I don't like feet
man I mean you know you need feet yeah
but you just don't like to like look at
I don't see some dudes feet well [ __ ] I
don't want to see it especially in a
public place
yeah Christ's sake fat old [ __ ] dude
was [ __ ] feet up well the thing about
it is like people in the theaters even
people that are actively being
douchebags like talking really loud or
whatever on their phone or whatever
which some people do and it's not just
you know people are picking on teenagers
and stuff it's old people - yeah you're
actually the worst they're actually
worse than young people I'm sure just in
my experience I'm gonna see them others
people's might be different but even you
know if somebody's sitting right there
and they got like popcorn or like
[ __ ] snacks or something there yeah
you know I mean go take a leak or
anything yeah and like I said then he's
gotta go to the bathroom in the in the
middle of it that he's gonna come back
home what'd I miss and I shut up I'm
trying to watch it yeah because that I'd
have to explain right but you do that at
home too though like you're always kind
of like what's going on and I'm like
this man that's I was like watching her
don't I'm not your movie tell her about
her yeah Xbox Xbox had like new stuff
and it really new really like I said
I'll let some of it looks like pretty
kick-ass yeah and then he also had old
stuff to all the class yeah I was I was
very happy too so they're movie rentals
they're movie rentals [ __ ] is good on
Xbox
did somebody now I'm gonna have to go
back cuz I don't remember like I get a
lot of comments on YouTube you know like
a lot of people like recommend movies to
me and stuff which I really appreciate
did somebody recommend that movie what
was it called Antrim
Antrim that's on there that looks good
and that's on there to rent yeah I think
that came out last year but like I said
2019 2020 because it's like sometimes
the [ __ ] just played at festivals and
hardly anybody got to see it yeah that's
the thing that these some of these indie
flix were done in festival
they got all kinds of [ __ ] awards and
they never even showed him in the movies
yeah theater now I will admit that well
because we were looking at the new
horror movies it's like I don't know if
they rank them by rating or they rank
it's our bed yeah when we got down to
the bottom I'm like wow this looks like
somebody just made this on there like
yeah 2012 phone had some Korean ones oh
yeah that one yeah that one actually
looks really good yeah it was called the
witch the wind but it wasn't like
anything to do with it was a Korean one
yeah it was a Korea was called the witch
subversion or something yeah it looked
like kind of like a little girl that had
been like by it you know modified by
damn nanites kind of like what was that
one that's showing now bloodshot yeah
looks like bloodshot but instead of a
big [ __ ] big [ __ ] ball dude it's
like a little [ __ ] schoolgirl yeah it
looked kind of similar it has something
we should probably review bloodshot but
I don't want to pay twenty dollars to
add to it yeah I'm gonna wait we'll wait
until it gets cheap it seems to be that
the online releases a couple weeks later
that they're available for renting yeah
yeah that's fine
those were 2020 movies yeah and they
only wanted three four dollars this is
the thing it doesn't make any sense
it's a brand-new movie they want to
charge you $20 you don't for a digital
download you're buying it but that's
just a digital copy yeah there's no
physical medium you wait a couple months
you'll be able to get the [ __ ]
blu-ray a DVD and a digital download for
20 bucks 20 bucks yeah sometimes less
yeah so how is that kind of a digital a
digital download for an on-time release
of a movie this plan in a theater should
be cheaper than the theater because
you're saying yes at your theater I mean
I know your band a damn expense I don't
mind them charging a little bit more cuz
in a written real movie right but I you
know maybe ten bucks but anything more
than that is pushing it well because I
mean it is I need about three or four
dollars more than a normal rental per
yeah think about it yeah so you're
talking it should be a little bit less
than nine bucks
eight bucks something like that yeah
that's it that seems reasonable yeah but
twenty dollars that's a little I mean I
don't mind paying $20 for like a blu-ray
that has like all the extra [ __ ] on it
but did
but not like just a digital download
that just seems like it I mean maybe if
you paid $20 I don't know if they give
you like extra material or not I would
think not with me because the movies for
a nail it's no fiscal there's no
physical backup to that thing yeah what
happen if you lost your account if you
guys suspend so you'd have to back it up
somewhere yeah it would just you know
and then you would be able to access
your [ __ ] what if your what if you wrote
a book that the powers would be didn't
like like that happened ever done any
neighbors they take all your [ __ ]
access to all your server you know all
your all your access away you know I
mean then you lose all that digital
content you bought yeah well like I said
that's why I back everything up yeah but
yeah so um what else like oh I wanted to
say that I was watching and this is
actually on youtube if you're interested
in watching it our friend Michael from
the starry night it was a cool band just
check yeah he for some reason he
messaged me yesterday and he's like you
got to see this two-part thing like a
documentary by Vice and it's on YouTube
called the dark side of the Ring
yes it's about wrestling I don't know
and it's like hardly anything about
wrestling like I knew hooch it Chris
Jericho was and he's he was kind of
instrumental making this so this is
about the very famous Chris Benoit case
he murders like the guy that murdered
his family and then killed himself and
it's actually really good it's like it's
two parts like I think they're each
about 45 minutes yeah but it was a case
that I didn't really I had kind of
vaguely heard about it but I didn't
really know all that much about it
it's not as crazy as tiger king well
nothing that's been I was like but it is
good since you've seen tide of like
since we've seen Tiger King it's like
now every other documentary is just like
the board really stated boring by
comparison Tiger king tiger King made
like Dog the Bounty Hunter look high
class yeah yeah yeah oh he's so fancy
yeah did he die oh no Dan he died uh-huh
am I completely like I haven't seen I've
seen that dude or seen or heard of that
dude [ __ ] like 10 years yeah a long
time sure I thought he died or someone
related to him dad like his wife her
thigh
remember I don't I don't keep up with a
lot of stuff but I mean I you know that
the dark side of the Ring thing it
reminded me a little bit of that other
that Netflix true-crime series that we
reviewed like probably a couple months
ago I think it was like about Aaron
Fernandes the football player it was
kind of similar to that because they
went into CTE like you know maybe like
repeated head injuries which actually is
way worse for wrestlers because they
don't wear helmets or anything and they
just like jump around laying on their
head each other wheelchair they ask each
other in the head with chairs and stuff
like that
yeah there's no trick to that they just
take it they just do it they just tense
up you hit him and I was like I'm
sitting there watching it going every
one of these dudes is an idiot breaking
there's yet not [ __ ] worse than pro
ballplayers
yeah that's what I'm saying cuz it's
like they at least I mean football
players yeah they run each of but at
least they have helmets on yeah
wrestlers don't they just like and and I
think Chris Benoit his thing was he
would like jump off he would do like a
flying headbutt or something so he's
like jumping off the corner of the ring
and like smashing into some [ __ ] head
like Lena and like I said you probably
pull up sometimes but some of the [ __ ]
that they showed with like them hitting
each other with like steel chairs and
stuff yeah that was clearly not fake and
those were real chairs so they went into
that and they also went a little bit
into um
steroid use and how maybe over like
excessive steroid use had maybe caused
him to flip out or anything like that
because I think is well his best friend
died and he didn't take it well which
you know I don't think was there it's
understandable but well they're saying
they don't know if it was cuz they said
that he was like super had like a lot of
like testosterone it was the head injury
I think it was probably the head is
because they did the same thing that
they did with that Aaron Fernandez guy
where it's like afterwards the
scientists really good we got to see
what this dude's brain looks like so and
when they autopsies it awesome that
autopsy sober but it's like the middle
of the deck but um yeah when they
autopsy them and they looked at the
brain they just said it was just like
[ __ ] like half eaten away just from
all the head injuries because he said
they asked him how many concussions he
had had in his life and he said he could
remember six concussions but there might
have been more
Matt yeah and I was like why would you
do that to yourself
they make it money I guess you see his
house he had a big [ __ ] mansion
that's why I was doing it I do it it
came from nothing yeah no but the shitty
thing is like some of them and some of
them like daeyoung t because his friend
Eddie like his best friend which kind of
scented sent him down the spiral he died
he was like only 38 years old or some
[ __ ] like that yeah and they said that
was heart failure but I'm sure that
might have had something taking drugs
too that's what I mean I think it had
something to do with that cuz that's all
very usual those kids were taken most
these dudes are taking roids
some sort of some sort or not yeah
modifying pharmaceuticals but they don't
do what that dude did and they don't all
die it's a it's a bunch of contributing
factors you just look at the
bodybuilding scene especially you go
back to the guys that were you know
during the Golden Age and the 70s and
how long they lived they they live good
lives for quiet for quite a while but
then then they died and they all kind of
died around the same time yeah I mean
and it's because of the amount of damn
oral steroids they were taken you know
the minute so then they try to find ways
around that way I would eject them and
all you some of this [ __ ] that these
dudes are taking nowadays to get as big
as they're getting it's like a whole
stack of [ __ ] yeah and then yet you have
to take a bunch of [ __ ] to get that big
and you got to take even more stuff to
counteract the bad effects of that [ __ ]
that you took so it's just a huge they
called a stack man [ __ ] huge stack of
drugs just just again it just to gain an
additional 20 pounds and again to get it
fast you can get [ __ ] 10 years where
the gains in about a year
see I just don't they're not patient
want to do that to yourself
it's like I guess like when when you're
young it's like you can I mean a lot of
shit's mitigated you can get away with a
lot of stuff when you're young cuz you
can bounce back from things but I was
like you know you get into your 30s or
40s that is gonna come back and bite you
in the ass Ben's on depends on who it is
you're talking about some of these young
guys you know they want instant
gratification you know and it's bigger
Exia yeah bigger Rexie it's like manna
resurrect matter xeo they want to call
it you know they're just not
enough which you know Lee priest gives
some good advice about that you know he
takes it but he said there's no reason
to take any of that [ __ ] until at least
you have five years worth of work behind
you you know see what your genetic
potential is yeah you know and when you
look at those dudes you know some guys
are kind of like on a borderline you can
tell that they're kind of enhanced you
go how much it's it's not like you don't
have to do it full-on some guys already
had good genes they worked out for a
long time and then they start taking
small enhancements and work out some
more and they might get some better
definition and put on another four or
five pounds you know when they probably
wouldn't been able to do that and it's
something they can kind of maintain
without being real super expensive or
real taxing but if you look at the
difference between enhanced and
unenhanced at that guys level not a big
difference you know I mean it's almost
kind of like nitpicking yeah I guess if
you're like on the competition circuit
and that's how you're trying to like
make money you're trying to get prize
money yeah and I think that's kind of
drying up now that seems changing a lot
you know yeah I think they're just doing
it because they want to look a certain
way and some guys want right now they
don't wanna ya put seven eight nine ten
years of work and you know well it's you
know I'm not doing it for that I work
out to try to [ __ ] expand your damn
lifes but you like span you know health
yeah and sometimes you get into are you
gonna get into those pharmaceuticals and
that might be detrimental you know yeah
now there's TRT testosterone replacement
therapy and some guys can do that when
they get older you know Tom Cruise
probably probably did that or maybe HGH
but you got to have a prescription you
got to know what you're [ __ ] doing
you know I mean then there's all kinds
of mood mood drugs to keep you from
[ __ ] acting like a fifteen-year-old
so because that would be horrifying yeah
codgers yeah [ __ ] everything that moves
and can be very dangerous well but I
think a lot of that [ __ ] man I've seen
there's guys like Chetty Orton who's
in his 70s had never took anything his
whole life and that dudes lived a long
time he looks fantastic he maintained
all that stuff yeah but I think it was a
mixture of discipline and good genes and
you know he worked out he liked it and
he wasn't rushing himself and he was
doing it for health which is really
close to the best races well that's
supposed to be the idea right yeah work
out to get big strong and healthy and
live a long time you know yeah some of
these guys and they're not in it for
that that's what I mean it's like that's
why it seems pointless that really seems
like the only legit reason
ra's pointless to take all these [ __ ]
drugs that are gonna probably shorten
your life yeah by a significant margin
same kind of mentality you saw between
like hot rodders instead of hot rodding
cars or hot rodding themselves you know
you just keep throwing money at the damn
car it gets more and more bigger and
bigger and faster and more ridiculous
and more and then you're gonna say show
and you go that is a [ __ ] ridiculous
you win I think that's I think that's
ridiculous true fee yeah bodybuilding is
not a sport either yeah they're gonna
say it's but now a bodybuilding is a
[ __ ] beauty contest that's what
it is essentially it's all subjective
depends on what the judges want and you
know you get some these dudes of theirs
are [ __ ] huge and you know I mean I
don't really think they look all that
good I don't think they look good at all
yeah they look powerful though but all
the limitations you know I mean those
guys can't even [ __ ] put their hands
behind your backs you know they're not
and that's what I mean did I mention
that before that it's like how do they
even wipe their ass yeah they own and
[ __ ] it they're doing squats
and some and you're supposed to do it
you know I like you see health is
supposed to be the ideal you know what I
mean and some of these guys are already
they can barely walk just [ __ ] to their
back all up from [ __ ] doing 4,000
pound squats or whatever you don't know
it just tears you up it is yea human
body is not really a built in that kind
of stress it's a it's weird because when
you were talking about like a bigger
axiom like taking the drugs and
everything I was reminded I was watching
something earlier today about Thelma
Todd it was like a silent screen you
know silent era
actress and she mysteriously turned up
dead in her car
they called it an accident maybe but
it's kind of sounded like a murder but
one thing that um that I thought was
kind of interesting and also kind of
horrible about her story was that in her
contract and this is like back in the
[ __ ] 20s they said okay well she was
122 pounds when they signed the contract
they said you cannot gain if you gain
more than three pounds or lose more than
six pounds or something like that then
the contract is null and void ridiculous
so she had to like be on diet pills
constantly yeah which you know was
probably back to speed probably out of
what year was this again 20s 1920s yeah
unrealistic expectations back that's
maybe three [ __ ] pounds yeah it's like
I can game three water right [ __ ] al
whoever wrote that contract had no idea
what the [ __ ] they were talking about oh
yeah what's the 1920s yeah nothing that
went down is that we're working on an
upcoming show we got it I got inspired
and Jenny said yeah if I'd be good idea
we did a show about it was very it was a
very popular show okay it was about fake
martial arts yeah all right Bushido
[ __ ] oh I touched upon a lot of
different subjects during that show that
we can kind of I want to kind of expand
upon and one of the ones that we got to
talk about
he's one of life's greatest mysteries
Steven Seagal we're gonna do a whole
show about Steven Seagal I think we will
yeah not like yeah it'll probably didn't
really be next month sometimes I'm true
crime and mystery show and paranormal
and all that's in Steven Seagal there's
a lot that's true crime I mean a
[ __ ] so human trafficker okay
he's he's human he's got charged with
human trafficking at one time Danny a
sexual assault or such the dude has to
be discussed all right is if it's gonna
be hilarious so I'm gonna put I'm gonna
put Jenny on him and then yeah well show
and I'll be able to cuz and and I'm not
hating on Seagal I like Seagal so got
his fur
few movies in a prize first five or six
movies we're good
they were good man but well we are
watching what gave us the idea because
like I said we'd been wanting to like
expand us yeah yeah but like we were
watching cinemassacre yeah just put up a
video and they were talking about what
the [ __ ] is the underseater season which
is that was but yeah one of the guys in
cinemassacre has what he calls a wall of
Segal yeah and he has every [ __ ]
thing and it's like not putting the
energy drinks
yeah he's even got the energy drinks
like from like 15 years ago he drank
them on the show and it's like he even
had like he had under siege he had it in
every possible format format yet on VHS
laserdisc you know none [ __ ] everything
yeah and it's like this guy it was just
so so funny that was a good movie I like
that movie you know it was like die hard
it was a lower budget version of die
hard but it had Gary Busey NN and had
Tommy Lee yeah and I had that girl pop
out of cake with her tits and [ __ ]
[ __ ] she was some Playboy bunny she
was cute yeah she was forced to kiss a
girl at the very end you could tell she
was not innocent man even it's funny
because I wonder how many takes they did
and it's like that's when they catch
their probably the other ones she was
probably like well pretty much it's
pretty much unanimous that people that
have worked with Seagal didn't find it
too enjoyable I can I can see that and
[Music]
it's like wait can we get a stunt double
in here for this double is like no we're
gonna go into his martial arts in
tomorrow his martial arts talked about
it's just such a rich vein of yeah and
was try to figure out what some of the
best products he came up with we're
gonna talk about some products like I
asked the energy drinks are [ __ ] not
out there anyway he had a damn
commercial for the end of energy drinks
it's [ __ ] hilarious I couldn't
believe that asian girl in the death
swimming pool he's calling her honey and
she's and she's pouring out all the
energy drinks into the pool she was what
was it two million cans you know what
it's called Asian experience yes
experience that was one of the flavors
yet he can wake up in a pool gonna jump
in the pool full [ __ ] energy drinks
with this asian girl and get it on that
was the commercial I I got the I I was
under the impression that it was funny
it all offered it was funny but they
showed it like all the show and I'm just
like that is not real it was real it was
real it was funny which kind of kind of
gave me a peek into [ __ ] Seagal is he
trying to be funny
I think he's slightly self-aware it's
are certain times because it's hard it
seemed like he was tongue-in-cheek you
know but he's also got Russian
connections we eat spends a lot of time
in Russian [ __ ] and [ __ ] Vladimir
Putin knows him and I just find it
amazing that this dude [ __ ] at his
way into a Hollywood career show
sometimes you can do it if yeah yeah he
pulled it you're in the right place the
right time when you [ __ ] the right
beer yeah and you and I it's harder did
you nowadays like I said because the
Internet is everything's on the internet
but back in the old days you could
pretty much just pull any old thing out
of your ass like I got some army stories
to tell about Segal my experiences in
the army with Steven Seagal we weren't
in the army together but we were in the
army we were watching Seagal movies yeah
and it's funny looking back on what we
believed to be true about Seagal yeah
and that was all pre-internet was he
like Elvis he could make it rain
we thought he was we thought because we
had heard that he actually was an
ex-navy seal but it didn't make any
sense he was too young when Deana that's
a long career to be a Navy SEAL yeah
what's he doing out you should have
still been in service you know and then
I saw him run in one of the movies and I
went oh no no no no no no no service man
no service man Navy SEAL armed what they
do not run like that they don't really
run is indescribable and then they were
kind of real um clever about
really really letting you see his bare
arms Segal's bear arms right and there
was at one time I got a glimpse of what
his arms look like and I was like no
maybe seals aren't built like that I
mean he kind of I want to say he had
girlish arms but the the definition was
that he's a big dude physically he's
probably six foot something yeah I
wouldn't tangle with him but the level
of physical fitness just wasn't there
[ __ ] Navy SEAL is basically an
Olympic swimmer mixed with a special
forces guy yeah you know I mean they got
they got [ __ ] high standards of
physical fitness and I was gone that's
kind of like that's kind of like
douchebag 101 it's like when you're
trying to like pick up chicks or
whatever it is you I'm a Navy SEAL yeah
I mean so many people do it that it's
like now even now even if you really
were a Navy SEAL no one would believe
yeah maybe she would never tell you he's
a Navy SEAL especially not a bar yeah
that's what I'm singing it's just it's
it's just like that thing where you know
if you're like a cool person
and you go around telling people you're
cool that means you're not cool yeah you
know saying well a lot of what seals do
they try to keep things real [ __ ] low
yeah and they're not the guy kind of
guys that go into a bar and start
bragging they might get in trouble for
some [ __ ] like yeah yeah so if anybody
comes up to you in a bar and says
they're a Navy SEAL they're not enemies
no just you know I'm sure most people
there was a dude that I would hang out
with and he just kind of seen military
to me and how long did it take me before
he finally admit to me that he was
Special Forces goddammit we went to his
house they went wait a minute
there's pictures of him on the wall in
his [ __ ] dress greens with his
[ __ ] tabbed he never sent a Special
Forces Group he had full auto weapons
and [ __ ] that he owned [ __ ]
suppressed [ __ ] full auto stuff in
there I'm going dude why don't you tell
me you were [ __ ] SF because he knew I
was in the service he just went yeah
like I said it seems like most people
that are in that yeah be that way and it
didn't even have a Facebook account yeah
he was like super yeah yeah we knew him
a long time we have a long time before
yeah
we didn't know until we went every
because he was some photographer and
well he had a lot of these little side
gigs yeah you know when he was home and
he didn't live on post they live in
civilian housing yeah where you can't
where like I guess you could say
intelligence enemy and Intel groups
can't figure out where they are because
they're not on a base right so you don't
know when they deploy they live in a
civilian world with girls and
girlfriends and [ __ ] and then they go
out and do [ __ ] and they're gone for six
months seven months and then they come
back and he came back and says where
were you and he was I was somewhere that
time to other uh because they just leave
without warning and come back without
warning and I know he came back from
Africa he was doing something in Africa
for a while that was a long time ago
sigh Kazakhs it yeah and he didn't give
me any details so so yeah what we're
saying is that if dude tells you he's a
Navy SEAL he's [ __ ] lying there's no
bar I was hanging out with SF Guide [ __ ]
yet even though he was selected
ex-military I didn't know why I was
getting along with him so well nobody
else seemed like him well some people
did yeah yeah he was just real quiet
real quiet you know why I wrote this one
yeah yeah and he knew everything about
me [ __ ] okay good [ __ ] ghost [ __ ]
ghost yeah and then once I [ __ ] in
his house and I see his [ __ ] picture
of him [ __ ] at his SF graduation and
[ __ ] yeah father you know long to call
him all kinds of [ __ ] he just
looked at me well hmm what are you gonna
do I think last time we saw him they ran
into him at like Home Depot or something
like that in the parking lot that was a
couple of years ago they'd seen him
since then alright you want to wrap up
yeah yeah cuz like I said I'm kind of
sleeping we got a record a show today
should I probably need a nap or some
[ __ ]
alright so we'll talk to you guys again
tomorrow